I'm Japanese so I'm expected to be a
pervert Yeah you are a perfect if I
don't
no I'm vanilla you
[Music]
all right so this LAPD officer just got
charged with sending nudes of his own
wife to other cops in the department
that is very normal oh whoa what the
hell what's this it is normal but it's
not cool uh yeah I don't know if it's
cool or not I don't like to judge people
normal doesn't mean justification by the
way it means comp I think common is like
they do that a lot yeah are you are you
joking are you serious right now so I
know pops commonly do crazy [__] like
that but it's not right yeah there's a
lot of people in the police department
all over the world
um it might be even a coping mechanism
because they see so much crazy [__] so
they have to send their [__] their
wives news it's like trading it's like
trading War Stories so people They smash
you know it's like it's like locker room
[__] too right like I'm sure athletes do
the same thing the people that they
smashed or whatever and then they they
enjoy it together and then some people
actually share Partners okay like hey
this person smashed me so good you
should try and then I can see that but
the wife though
do you feel like do you feel like man my
wife she complains so much I don't see
her like I used to can somebody
appreciate her because I can't do it no
more bro
I want to see another man go like oh my
God one man catch another man's treasure
oh you want to see okay and in your life
oh I remember now I remember what a bad
girl you are you know in a weird Twisted
way when like I don't know I like it
when people like when people like would
leak my nudes back in the day I'd be
like
and it looks good what the [__] like I'm
like and but I was about this life for
for many years I had no other options
this is this this was like titties or
nothing you know yeah it's just
different if you're not trying to be
about that it's a private thing I shared
it with my husband what the [__] so the
worst part is is it wasn't like she took
news of herself oh he went with her to
like a doctor's appointment that's so
funny
nah it was like her uh I think she was
getting like an augmentation because
that's not even consensual photo
non-consensual and not even a sexy
picture that's medical bro it was like
before like before the surgery or after
yeah both he he took photos of her but
like when the doctor's examining her and
then he shared it to him he's like look
at his doctor touching my wife's tits
first of all weird that he did that like
weird in general why would he send it in
the group chat when you could easily
just like show it from your phone like
this and have no trace of doing that no
not suggesting anything are you stupid
like you could easily be like check this
out
yeah yeah right right we have friends
that would always send um penis like
their penis or other yeah they're them
they're all on accident on accident no
not really on purpose lease on purpose
yeah on purpose and work group chats too
and we're like what the [__] dude damn
yo I removed myself we'll send each
other our nudes and like critique them
and be like um Arch it a little more but
that makes sense because it's your work
yeah
like being in college and being and
having my friend being like yo I'm gonna
spread my ass cheeks get underneath do
it we're sending it to this guy you know
like and I would always be like bet I'm
here for you like point five angle
trying to make it like spread my ass
cheeks but like taking pictures of
someone on a vulnerable moment and then
sharing it without their consent is
[__] crazy the funny thing is she
started catfishing on to it because she
would be hanging out like with the other
girls like more than once talk about her
like they would make it do you know when
[__] guys make it so [__]
and they were just like hey your
husband's a lucky man you know yeah nice
surgical titties yeah they would just
like make these little comments and
she's like what the [__] why are they
saying that and then she like checked
his phone and then saw that he had sent
it throughout all these different chats
yeah what a son of a [__] you guys
think that's divorce territory yeah
it's not like an accident that's like
this was the range
it's just been like all the other things
that are minor that's what it's saying
yeah that shows his threshold yeah he
like kicks dogs or something like he
probably sees like orphan
do that with his wife imagine just
people like on the street that he's like
at work
and he's supposed to be in a position of
authority too right so he has extra you
know clout for himself he should get
fired and divorced done yeah throw it in
jail
but he might like the golden shower
though because he sounds like a freak I
once threw a party like it was when
Donald Trump was president when I got
like a pinata and I was like guys let's
have a [__] piss party let's have a
pee pee party like let's drink a bunch
of Pedialyte and like what we did
Donald Trump pinata and we were just
like
I thought you just [__] I wasn't like
gone before it was like also it was a
lingerie party so it was all of us like
in our underwear and we were just curb
stopping the [__] out of this pinata
[Applause]
dude that's so [__] up dude
everybody's pissed everybody everybody
that's really [__] up that's so [__]
up I don't know I don't know why I don't
even know
how funny that's so [__] up that would
look kind of oh wow I'm amazing you got
pee pee all over the floor
[Laughter]
this wasn't for Conte it was just for
your own entertainment it honestly [__]
was funny but it just kind of kept going
again she is a [__] rock star bro
like it was kind of like going too far
once we like started setting it on fire
I was like okay okay
slitting their wrists and stuff like
that everybody started putting on
[__] goat helmets like At first I was
like haha then I was like I I don't know
that you're in flame sounds crazy
customer's like and she said she won't
[__] on a Filipino flag
it was like if you saw it and if you saw
the sight of all these naked Asian women
in their underwear like just curves
Donald Trump women only and also Asian
women but that wasn't on purpose that
was just it just happened like today
yeah yeah I was just like
Asian day yeah Asian day right so your
friend group is Asian I would say at the
time a lot when I was exploring my
sexuality a lot of it was fellow Asian
women because I feel
like experiencing her sexuality and
embracing it and then navigating the
dating world is like such a similar I
don't know how it is being a horny Asian
dude I don't know what your life is like
yeah just find other horny Asians you
sit down you [__] talk about [__]
because you can't get [__] I'm Japanese
who looked at you funny I'm Japanese so
I'm expected to be a pervert Yeah if I
don't
no I'm vanilla
that's pretty tame for Japanese
standards all right because I'm not
buying dirty underwear and going oh I'm
not food a smear you know what I mean
you're also not vanilla you're not an
underwear I'm chocolate
chocolate malted crunch over there
pretty normal when you guys were growing
up did you guys have like internalized
racism with your own asianist because at
the time this is really stupid when I
was younger I didn't think being
Filipino was cool I didn't think it was
oh but all the break dancers are
Filipinos what city did you grow up in
at that time L.A native well like what
part of L.A though because it that
matters like Eagle Rock that's cool
that's like Filipino did you want to be
Armenian or what nope I wanted to be
Japanese
oh it's our generation bro that's why
because all the Filipinos were the cool
Asians when we were growing up yeah yeah
no but like the Japanese and Koreans in
my high school they were cool and swaggy
as [__] so like when people would be
like what type of Asian are you I'd be
like oh yes so there weren't as many
Filipinos in your eyes there was hella
Filipinos but I just felt like they were
just like they were completely swagless
no drip that's crazy that's like the
opposite all the Filipinos dressed as
best they were into the coolest Fashions
they're always in to the like like the
best like oh we're dancing or they were
kind of more integrated with hip-hop
culture yeah yeah we are kind of swaggy
now I think we've like gotten our
Renaissance we're cool we're getting
cool restaurants of us now let's let's
go
it is hard to get a Filipino restaurant
out here by the way yeah what do you
mean is it there's not a lot of Filipino
restaurants I'm not enough like swag
there's hell Japanese restaurants hello
Korean restaurants hello Thai
restaurants hell of Vietnamese
restaurants it's not a lot of Filipino
because all the Japanese restaurants are
also not Japanese either they're
Japanese a lot of them are Korean huh
yeah
a lot of the a lot of the Fall
restaurants
so I grew up mainly around Mexican and
black right where L.A native uh Gardena
so then so then when I'm here
so now when I moved to Monterey Park
that was my that was my Asian experience
and I was like there's Asians in L.A and
I was like there's so many [__] hot
Asian girls what the [__] because back
then Asian girls are late to bloom
meaning like Mexican and black girls
they have a woman's body already I
bought these titties at 35. and then the
way they dress is like they're more like
fashionable whatever because Asian girls
they're like their parents are like you
can't [__] dress like this and they
dress most of the girls until a certain
age right but then when you get into
high school and if you're from a more
like ghetto ass asian neighborhood yeah
I was in ABG for sure yeah ABB oh my God
wait you don't look like an ABG at all
[Laughter]
this is what we look like yeah this okay
this like the import model look yeah
it's like lash extensions like hair like
this titties like they're like if you
know like Danny real and Like That
Ashley V it's like those they look like
they got a switchblade in their purse
you know what I mean okay yeah back then
it's always spaghetti straps flared out
jeans [__] like drawn in eyebrows and
yeah switch blades yeah my favorite
things so they could get with these kind
of girls like a hot chick that'll stab
you to yeah like Suki Suki for fast food
so Cuba will slap the [__] out of you
feisty
obviously like the Original Gangster ABG
which is like she's like from like North
North Long Beach and like she's like
hard and sometimes they shave their
heads yeah no they're hard
or anyone that hangs out with them but
she don't want to do it I don't know how
to dude did you like toss me in there
I'm getting my my implants popped I'll
be like she goes into these fires
as you grow up Filipino it is true that
other um other Asians don't watch
Filipino entertainment but Filipinos do
watch anime and they listen to K-pop
yeah so it is a little bit you do feel
alone yeah that does feel less cool and
nobody grass is greener bro because like
I feel like light-skinned Asians will
look at like Filipinos and be like man
you guys have all the parties all the
fun all the dancing we got cold ass
families that don't kiss each other and
[__] I don't kiss my family in the Asian
Community y'all have like light skin and
dark skin yeah
like crazy we got them jungle Asians you
know what I'm saying Filipinos were
usually at the bottom because how do
y'all treat y'all it's not everybody
thinks it's a [__] ladder it's a
[__] Circle it just depends on which
side you're looking at it how did how do
Asians like treat like how do they rank
up yeah yeah like like light skin we're
dark skinned Asians which is hilarious
because what and then they're like
light-skinned Asians yeah well the
funniest thing
colorism doesn't really exist in Japan
only in within women because like you
could be a dark ass dude and still be
like but also they got in their own in
the Philippines as long as you got
light-skinned dark skin if you're a dark
skin it's like you work in the field so
you're the people
yeah you're light-skinned Filipino in
the Philippines you're like high class I
think Philippines go hard with that
stuff because they like do the skin
bleaching and [__] that's not Universal
exactly yeah exactly and like they're
yeah my mom was like bleaching my skin
back you had to do that yeah yeah
but now I like
the sun you're protected by the Sun
[Music]